this is Star Talk things you thought you
knew Edition this is where we reveal the
science underbelly of things that are
just in our lives that maybe you never
thought about and I got with me my
co-host Chuck nice as always let's dig
[Music]
in Chuck yes I I got a fast one for you
all righty this one is going to be about
Wheels oh okay I'm going to say uh I'll
say a bit pedestrian for you just
okay would it be any more pedestrian
than water towers oo good point only our
viral still the most popular one of
these that we've done I think would have
never thought that one would have landed
the way it did couple couple million
people were just like water towers
man got to know about the water towers
this is amazing like five five million
views yeah I know that's funny oh my God
water
towers so maybe the wheels will do the
same thing you ready okay okay so did
you
know that if you're driving down the
road okay pick a speed 60 miles an hour
n that ain't me oh okay whatever sorry
you gotta bump that up by about 25 miles
and now we talking
at whatever speed you're going okay
there is a part of your car all right
that is going forward at zero miles per
hour at all times all right this already
got interesting because I okay I have no
idea what you're talking about right now
there's another part of your car that's
going forward at twice that
speed at every moment oh God okay go
Jesus
okay all right so okay you ready okay
are you seated okay here we go okay here
we go okay it's all happening in your
wheels so the part of the wheel at any
moment oh my God
that's contact with the
pavement is not moving at all that's
right damn
it's no if your car were skidding right
then the part of the wheel in contact
with the road would be moving forward
would be moving forward at the rate
you're skidding forward but that's why
you're moving forward it's it's why
you're moving forward it's why you're
moving forward because part of the wheel
is not moving at all exact because if it
were you'd be spinning in place that
You' be spinning in place correct by the
way okay now you know what man you did
it again you did it
again cuz I'm a let I I'm no I I gotta
say I now I'm first of all this is what
I'mma do right now I'mma publicly
apologize to you for all that I was
thinking cuz I was think let me tell you
something I was thinking some stuff I'm
apologize to you right now cuz you were
like all right Chuck we're going to talk
about Wheels I'm like this brother done
lost his damn mind we going to talk
about Wheels
seriously but you did it go ahead let's
go for it let's keep going let's keep
going so the center of the wheel right
which
is okay it's spinning but the exact
center is going forward at the same
speed the car is absolutely okay the top
of the
wheel is going forward at twice the
speed of the car twice the speed of the
car okay just like a at twice the speed
right wow okay because notice if the
chassis of the car is moving at the
speed of the car obviously the top of
the wheel is moving faster than the
chassis right
okay it's moving past the chass past the
top of the wheel well the wheel well the
top of the wheel well is going forward
at your speed at your speedometer speed
the top of the wheel is going faster
than that to come around to the bottom
so that it's not moving moving at all
that's inred if if you run the math on
that you get you get zero at the bottom
the speed of the car in the middle of
the wheel and twice the speed of the car
at the top of the wheel and so this is
this is the geometry the math and the
physics of a of an axled wheel on any
moving
vehicle you
Chuck
check Chuck smoking something I'm just
saying I'm ready to talk about this all
day Chuck is smoking okay but
but but wait there's more that's awesome
that is awesome but wait there's so you
a DOT on the wheel and a DOT at the
chassis and then it comes up it has to
go faster than the faster has to go
faster so it can come the top of the
wheel well that's right so it can come
around correct so now damn now now think
of the wheel that's on a
train okay the train wheels are
different all right the different from
car wheels obviously so there's the
metal flat part that touches the the
metal rails but then there's another
part that's like an outer outer what's
the where should I use that it's like a
coupler there's an outer part that
extends outside of the track right okay
can you picture this it's not just
rolling on a track it's like a lip like
a lip on the wheel itself a lip that
extends outside of the track which
enables the train to stay on the track
otherwise it'll just drive off right so
these lips that are exterior to the
wheels keep the train aligned on the
track okay right but here's what's
interesting they
dip
below the contact point of the wheel and
the rail
correct that by a little bit but
whatever it is they dip below right all
right well if the top of your wheel is
going twice the speed the center of the
wheel is going the speed the bottom of
the wheel is going zero anything lower
than the bottom of the wheel is moving
backwards oh
snap that's right okay okay it's going
in reverse it's going
reverse so for any train there are parts
of that train that are moving backwards
on the track at all
times wow that's that's pretty wild and
it just just picture that you know
there's the wheel rolling the part
that's below the contact point is moving
backward it actually land in a place
behind where it started right that means
it moved backwards that's right that's
insane that's so I just thought I'd put
that out there I know it's not nothing
deeper than that it's just the next time
i' tie up a woman and put her on the
tracks I'mma let her know that this
you're gonna learn
something is this what you do Chuck okay
as I as I twirl my
mustache now here's here's something
interesting are you ready so that means
there's a part of your car that's going
at all speeds from zero up to twice the
speed of the car correct that's right
okay so imagine this imagine attaching
some device to your
wheel that sends out a microwave signal
and you can adjust it up or down okay
from the center of the wheel to the
outer rim and sends out or or or from
the center of the wheel to the bottom
sends out a microwave
signal that will report a speed of your
car at any speed you
choose so the police officer there with
the radar gun oh with the return signal
that's going 30 miles an hour even
though you're going
60 yes so so they'll get the reflected
signal off of your car right but if you
can override that with a more powerful
signal from your wheels you can
broadcast any speed you choose down to
zero if it's attached to the wheel right
which is the that's the speed I'm
choosing by the
way well you can't do zero because they
know you're lying well
that's any place any place between the
center of the wheel and the bottom
bottom of the wheel it will you can
broadcast a speed of that spinning wheel
at any speed less than your actual
driving speed wow but it it would to to
configure this would be really weird and
how to make that happen because it has
to be moving with the tire I don't know
how you would design the engineering of
that but it's just something to think
about because there's always a part of
your car that's going everywhere from
the speed of your car down to zero and
up to twice the speed of the car well
maybe you know when the cop pulls you
over you can just tell him I don't know
what speed you record it but uh it I
don't know you should should have been
looking at the bottom of my
wheels yeah that'll work in
[Laughter]
court so that's all I have to say about
Wheels that's uh that was um pretty damn
good I mean sorry pardon my language
that was pretty dog going good that that
now there's completely surprised taken
taken aback by this
one yeah and there's another kind of
wheel which is the shape of the object
that rotates within a wankle engine so
if you imagine an equilateral triangle
but curve the corners of it and make the
sides a little bit convex right so it's
a triangle I had a Mazda once oh you did
was it a with a wankle engine okay so so
that shape
interestingly the distance from the
bottom to the top right Remains the Same
no matter how it's
oriented so if you roll it along long
the if you I made one of these shakes in
fact I don't have one with me here we
might have to do another explainer we
used to call them spirographs when I was
a kid okay yeah so they're related
they're related right they're related
geometry to it so if you take a plank
and place it on top of one of these
triangular shapes and roll it the plank
will be absolutely steady even though it
looks like the thing is bobbing up and
down it's because there's no Central
axle to it right okay we think a wheel
needs a wheel that gives you a smooth
ride needs one Central axle because a
wheel is the same distance to each point
on the rim you can design a shape where
the top is always the same distance from
the bottom even though the center is
moving in your spiral graphi and sort of
way nice so I actually built one of
these when I was a kid in in wood shop
in seventh grade and I don't think it's
with me here that is a closet somewhere
I'm going to have to dig it up and we'll
do another one just fun things to do
with with a wankle engine nice yeah it's
an unfortunate name but yeah I know
right it's a little weird it is a little
weird but it's one of the many engines
that have been developed over the years
to convert uh chemical energy into
kinetic energy and so maybe we'll do it
I know we'll do a an explain art just on
engines in the history of engines oh
that's a great why they differ from each
other and and where they're headed that
that that's a good one that is a good
one and now you know that part of your
car ain't moving at all but don't use
that as the excuse when you get pulled
over that's it that's it or don't
experiment with how the cop will react
if you give that as an excuse right you
don't
want we've got to take a quick break but
when we come back the second segment of
things you thought you knew on
Star
we're back Star Talk things you thought
you knew Edition still here with my
co-host Chuck nice let's dig right in
Chuck another explainer okay is bubbling
up within me ah okay now you sure that
that's an
explainer or go to the bathroom and I
was gonna say what you have for lunch CU
you
[Laughter]
know so so I was just thinking how much
we take for granted about when we use
the word
energy
and it has profound Origins I mean our
understanding of energy has profound
Origins the Brilliance of Isaac nton who
you know discovered the laws of Optics
and gravity and motion and and invented
calculus energy was not a fully
developed Concept in his time right and
so so I just want to sort of spend a few
minutes offering an
appreciation for for a Triumph of the
human intellect to figure out what the
hell energy is and then how to
manufacture it and exploit it I just
want to spend a few minutes this is like
a public service announcement for energy
nice out there energy is not a thing
right you can say a rock is a thing and
you can point to it or planet is a thing
and energy is not a thing so it was
delayed in our ability to understand
what it was and how to think about it so
we knew some things for example when you
had a cannon back when cannons were like
a popular tool in Warfare right there
were physicists at the time who said hm
I have a cannon ball and have this
gunpowder and the cannon is made of ir
iron then I fire it and if I keep doing
this the cannon gets hotter and
hotter well where's that heat coming
from so what is it and so in the urge to
turn energy into a thing early ideas was
that there was energy was a fluid was a
thing that could move in and out of
objects okay one of them they called it
another one was a
caloric these were words invented to try
to think
about energy as an as a thing and then
it moves and it's got to be somewhere
and and so a hot Cannon had more of this
in it than a cold Cannon and so and so
there was you had to start somewhere we
were crawling before we even could walk
and it wasn't until we understood
molecules and atoms and and that we were
able to say
h and and what role friction plays in
this we able to
say so you can store
energy in different
ways and when you store it it's not
manifesting itself it's not saying here
I am look it's not really doing that and
when you're storing it no the object is
not in motion no the object is not you
know it's not all these things that it
is when it's manifesting so let's take
the simplest case a roller coaster okay
right every roller
coaster the first
Ascent is the highest yeah okay so
what's going on so there you go and
you're leaning back and this thing
cranks you up it is endowing you with
energy potential potential energy stored
energy potential gravitational energy
when you get to the top you can
calculate how because we have formulas
for this calculate how much
gravitational energy it handed you so I
don't feel this energy I don't know what
you're talking about until I push you
over that ledge right over the other
side of that hill then what happens is
your potential energy starts
converting to mechanical energy to
kinetic energy and it's an exact
tradeoff an exact trade-off so all that
energy they gave you at the top right
okay now is returned with you speeding
up as you descend and that is
when sandwich becomes actual
vomit
okay that's a a transformation of
another
[Laughter]
kind um so and it's this tradeoff and it
goes back and forth as you go up hills
and down if you go up a shorter Hill
than the first one okay you have enough
energy to reach the top of that Hill
because you started out with way more
energy than that at an even higher Hill
right you're gonna lose some energy to
friction okay so in other words you
can't Ascend back to a hill exactly the
same height that you started in okay
some energy will go to friction and when
you lose energy to friction that makes
heat okay that's the source of heat when
you lose energy all right so that's why
the engine of your car gets hot right
okay not all the energy that you started
with got transferred to the motion of
the car the losses went to friction the
friction heated your engine your engine
gets hot okay so in a roller coaster
you're converting gravitational
potential energy to kinetic energy and
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and if they designed it
right the frictional energy that you
lose okay you don't go up higher and
higher the hills you go over have to get
lower and lower and there's the last one
then you come in for the stop right so
they they gave you the energy when you
started at the top of that hill so
that's gravitational potential energy
becoming kinetic energy that that's
what's going on there and like I said if
you go back up a shorter Hill
you'll slow down because some of that
kinetic energy is giving back to you so
you can have another little lump of of
potential energy to take the next Hill
that comes after that all right so
that's easy we've had roller coasters
forever you could have imagined them
forever ago but it's more complicated or
a little more physics involved if you
want to say this molecule has energy
right a
molecule well how am I going to get the
energy out of the molecule just sitting
there oh well you can in one case burn
it burn the molecule okay why is it that
you can throw a log in the
fire and the log is room temperature you
put in the fire then the fire ignites
the log and the log keeps burning
there's there's chemical potential
energy in the molecules of the
log where did that energy come from
where did the log get that energy Chuck
you tell me right now the log it's it's
it from its molecules it was
storing where did its molecules get
their
energy okay let me think about this
um oh from their
atoms what did the log used to be no it
used to be a tree a tree how does a tree
get energy um from the Sun thank you
thank you so
this the sun builds molecules that
contain stored energy so that's why wood
burns because it has stored chemical
energy given to it by the sun look at
that and it's it's just sitting there
mining its own business right but that's
why fires and homes are so deadly
because there's all this potential
energy stored in the molecules of
organic matter wood if your house is
made of wood right so that the whole
thing
Burns converting the chem the chemical
energy into thermal
energy wow so so much of our Lives is
the conversion of energy of one form
into another and what happens while
that's going
on so other forms of En there's energy
in the nucleus of an atom yes you split
the nucleus and take it out we make
bombs doing that okay so we turn nuclear
energ energy into the kinetic energy of
an explosion to do damage to things in
Warfare gosh okay that's nuclear or
chemical energy some chemicals will give
you their energy not slowly like a
slowly burning log right they'll give it
to you catastrophically all right and we
call those bombs okay or a firecracker
catastrophically Boom the energy goes to
break apart the firecracker goes into
the sound
that it makes the shock wave all of that
so our lives and everything we do is
nothing but a a ballet of the conversion
of energy from one form into another so
but think about it so you eat food that
has you look at the calorie content
that's how much energy it has okay so
then you consume it you need energy to
live to move your heart beats all this
requires energy you're getting it from
the calories of the food you eat so what
happens if you consume more calories
than you need got to store body says
store that store that energy so it
creates it creates chemical potential
energy in the form of fat and it stores
it away I'm not fat I'm just filled with
[Music]
potential what you talking about you see
this this is potential
I am potentially Michael B Jordan I am
potentially Michael B Jordan that's what
the
[Laughter]
potential my six-pack is just beneath
the potential all this potential you
don't even know what you can have I
don't even know what you can have no one
knows what you can have because it's all
potential and by the way that conversion
of your body's calories to your energy
is not perfectly efficient so what
happens
to that excess energy that's not
converted it's that's the inefficiency
of your body all we're an engine of
sorts it's inefficient so that
inefficiency gets converted to heat so
your body heats up when you exercise
right that's it's a consequence of the
inefficiency of your body but your body
loves that because now you it's part of
your temperature regulating system but
I'm just saying you when you exercise
your body heats up in the same way you
drive a car the car heats up in the same
way the the wheels and the tracks of a
roller coaster are actually getting hot
because of the inefficiencies of the
conversion because there's
inefficiencies in every conversion of
energy from one form to another so the
only point of this explainer is just to
say so much of what we do and how we
live involves the clever conversion of
energy from one form to another nuclear
energy molecular um chemical energy
which is molecular uh we have kinetic
energy gravitational energy all of this
right comes together and our ability to
exploit that in the service of
civilization is one of the great
triumphs of physics especially 19th
century physics look at that where they
figured out oh my gosh look what we can
do another quick one just look a
locomotive right what's going on there
well the locomotive all right I don't
know if you remember they'd have to fill
up with from water tanks every now and
then okay well what does the water do
well a locomotive Burns either coal or
wood and it Heats a so that's the
chemical energy it Heats a vat of water
so it's get the stored chemical energy
of the wood into the active thermal
energy of the vibrating water molecules
they then evaporate create creating
pressure for the steam to then move
Wheels to have the locomotive go forward
nice oh my gosh and that all started
with solar energy that made the wood or
the coal that made the the the fire that
made the boiling water that made the
pressure that moved the wheels uh oh all
of this a Triumph of our understanding
of energy now what you just said there I
can hear Exxon going listen guys
we're actually solar energy okay
so we got I just see it coming now
ultimately ultimately guys started as
solar energy this is solar energy okay
fossil fuels started as solar energy
this is true damn this is true it
reminds me and we got to end right now
it reminds me of this bumper sticker
that says no nukes right right from the
anti-nuke movement and then the O in the
no is an image of the
sun no nukes no nukes okay yeah exactly
I know what they mean they want you do
solar energy but the sun makes his
energy with nukes right all right just
like make that clear yeah here that's
how that it started that way so anyhow I
just thought I put all that out there
cool and so to just to enhance our
appreciation for what energy does for us
and how being clever has enabled us to
build civilization on the exploitation
of converting energy from one form into
another yeah it has built civilization
and ultimately it will destroy
civilization destroy on that happy note
Chuck thank you we got to take a quick
break but when we return the third and
final segment of star talks things you
thought you
knew we're back Star Talk things you
thought you knew addition in this
segment Chuck and I continue to explore
the science that lives in the underbelly
of things you always thought you knew
Chuck what do you know about
Medusa um I don't want to see her I know
that if if she ever said to me uh look
here I'm like
no not looking no I'm not looking what
you mean look here ah
yeah she makes eye contact with you you
turn to Stone right and she's famously
in the night sky she's immortalized the
severed head of Medusa is immortalized
held by the Perseus Perseus is a
constellation in the sky and there's a
star called
alol which is a variable star it changes
its brightness um over relatively short
periods of time that's why we call them
variable Stars and the eye of the
severed head is alol so this is Medusa
like looking at you it's pretty fun and
of course Perseus was the hero in the
story with Andromeda who is the daughter
of
copia and she was I don't remember why
oh copia said she was more beautiful
than the C nymphs and then then out of
punishment they took her daughter and
strapped her to the cliffs and for the
sea monster to come devour her
and Perseus the Kraken right and so the
Perseus comes to save to save her but he
can't get there on foot so out of the
seaf foam Rises up Rises up uh Pegasus
Pegasus and he flies on the back of
Pegasus oh he has to slay Medusa all
right right and so he does it by looking
at her but through the reflection of his
shield okay and that way it's not a
direct direct sight line I can't believe
for
that and and backs up to her and slays
her backwards right that was pretty cool
and cuts off her head and puts it in a
in a in a sack perus is in the sky um
rides on the back to go save Andromeda
by showing the severed head of Medusa to
the Kraken and the Kraken turns to Stone
and then crumbles away cuz he's too big
to be stoned right I got to say that's a
big chance that percus took
that you know the severed head would
still be able to do its thing good yeah
yeah rather than just with closed
eyelids right you have to like pry open
the eyelids with toothpicks or something
exactly cuz you know a lot of times you
know he had to make sure she died with
her eyes open probably from the surprise
the surprise of falling for that stupid
trick of looking at her through a shield
so she died with her eyes like I can't
believe that I fell for this
like
is that what she sounds like is that
voice that's Medusa God I can't believe
I fell for this
dup okay so all of them are in the night
sky we got Andromeda Medusa uh
copia the reason why I'm saying all this
is there's a whole set of
Legends that derive from the
expectation that when you look at
someone or anything that you're sending
out some
beam of energy or information or light
as though seeing was an
active aspect of what it is to obtain
information right so I see you because
because I'm going out there and I'm
getting you bringing you back into back
in right right right so that is not how
seeing works and this was not
established until about 1300 years ago
in the Middle East in what we s call the
Golden Age of Islam uh alhazen uh
occasionally referred to as uh alhan
both of those I think are legitimate
names for him one of the great
scientists of the era early an early
scientists in the history of scientists
um kept good notes had hypotheses of how
things worked he looked at a cow eyeball
saw a lens saw that you can make an
image on the back of the eyeball and and
he deduced that the active sight is 100%
passive all
reception all reception so you can't
just give someone the google eyes and
have them say oh I feel someone's
looking at me people will still say that
but all experiments show that no you
cannot tell if you do it in a in a
controlled setting you cannot tell when
someone's looking at you okay unless
you're in the subway
cuz sometimes in the subway and you just
get that feeling that comes up the back
of your neck and you turn and there is
some creepy person staring at you and
they don't turn away they will not
that's that's how you know you're in New
York any other place you look at
somebody and they look away like oh
shoot I was staring they look sheepish
about I can't believe I was staring you
in New York you turn at them and they're
just like that's right I'm going to kill
you like
it's don't scare people from the New
York City Subways that's not what here's
my point anytime you turn around because
you think someone's staring at you and
they are staring at you right you have
not recorded the thousands of times
people were also staring at you and you
didn't turn around to notice okay so
this this is when you do the control
setting this this is the case so it's
just an interesting fact the Bible story
is about who was it that turned back and
she became a pillar of salt Lot's wife
is it because she observed or because
the no because Sodom and Gomorrah the
light from Sodom gorah reached her eyes
which was it my Bible stories here no no
that was correct it it was it was
actually both of that both those things
she observed the destruction of Sodom
and Gomorrah and they were told whatever
you do do not look back and so she
violated the the directive looked back
at the destruction and turned to stone
in doing so okay so that case that might
not be her sending out a signal from her
eyeballs so that sounds like a more
legit uh consequence of this relative to
Medusa looking at you her eyes light up
and then you turn to Stone so so I just
it's an interesting history how you can
there can be mythologies that rise up
around physiological misconceptions that
make for interesting stories right and
people used to be thought of as dying of
a broken heart all right uh maybe it
wasn't an actual heart attack all right
but then you know there it was bacon
bacon Francis Bacon or bacon it was just
bacon the bacon that's just like he died
of a broken heart no no that's called
cholesterol that's called cholesterol
the man had bacon with every single meal
and you know you can't do what you can't
you don't want to take away the romance
of dying of a broken heart that's all no
so it's just it's just fun so I don't I
don't object to misconceptions if you
have no better explanation at the time
and it becomes part of sort of our
cultural sense of the world I mean
that's this is what um this is the
richness and the depth of history that
we experience as a culture who knows
what they'll be saying about know here's
here's the problem with that though see
what someone of your particular
Acuity can say that can say this is part
of the wondrous Romance of lifearm
elements of charming Elements of Life
that we're able because you're a person
who understands the scientific method
you're somebody who uh uh you know
believes in data and empiricism you know
both okay but the problem with that that
Charming that wonder that you know these
these these idiosyncratic you know
things that happen um that we attribute
meaning to them you know that we're
attributing that meaning we are a fixing
meaning to those things they don't
really have meaning the problem is there
are a bunch of dumb asses
who who actually
believe okay they believe this it it's
no okay there's no excuse once we've
learned how all this works there's no no
excuse to continue to think it's true
and that's what you're talking about the
people who are are delayed in their
acceptance of objective Realties and I I
with you there but I'm not going to
judge people from long ago on today's
standards okay I'm going to say okay no
no we're well y you got me yeah that's
that's I got to give it to you there
they're they're they're perfectly
acceptable they had no other information
so therefore boom I get it exactly
exactly and you know right on down to
those who imagined that someone having
an epileptic seizure were being invaded
by the devil right right and so you go
get the priest and they do the holy
water and out these symptoms the seizure
is over the 20 minute seizure ends it
just ended because how far weighs the
church 500 years ago it's like two
blocks away right just in time for the
priest to get there so I it's it's we're
trying to make sense of the world and so
I don't you know I'm I'm so funny you
use that that that as an example because
I think it's a great example because we
can actually see the brain now we can
see the activity of the brain and
exactly what is happening in the brain
that causes this epileptic fit so there
is we're not seeing the devil what we're
seeing is a neurosynaptic breakdown or
malfunction right and so you know but
where did the devil go you know like if
you want to believe that right but fine
in the face of science just don't lead
any science agencies that allocate
research
funding job for you with it's in a
society all right Chuck we got to end it
there all right all right this this been
yet another star talk explainer on some
random subject you never thought you
might be interested in and maybe you're
still not I don't
know who might have tell well we're out
of time that's a wrap on Star talks
things thought you New Edition Chuck
always good to have you I'm Neil degrass
Tyson your personal astrophysicist as
always I did you to keep looking
[Music]
up